-Well, Election Day may be over,
but the ballot
counting continues,
with Joe Biden tentatively ahead
in enough states
to win the presidency
and, as expected,
the president and his allies
are falsely declaring victory,
lying to discredit the results,
and trying to stop the count
altogether.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We're taping this at 5:00,
so we can't say what will happen
as states continue
counting ballots,
and they should all be counted,
but as we're taping this,
the president's path
to victory is narrowing.
Wisconsin and Michigan
have both been called for Biden
and, as New York Times
election analyst Nate Cohn
noted, Biden...
Or, as Trump put it,
in his unhinged,
middle-of-the-night
complaint fest...
-This is a fraud
on the American public.
This is an embarrassment
to our country.
We were getting ready
to win this election.
Frankly,
we did win this election.
[ Cheering ]
We have won Georgia.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We're up by 2.5%, or 117,000
votes, with only 7% left.
They're never going to catch us.
They can't catch us.
Likewise, we've clearly won
North Carolina.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Where we're up 1.4%.
Or 77,000 votes, with only
approximately 5% left.
They can't catch us.
-Alright, first of all,
yeah, they can catch you,
since you lumber
like a retired Frankenstein
looking for a golf ball
in a sand trap.
Second, no,
you haven't won those states.
You might win some of them,
once the counting is done,
or you might lose them,
but the counting isn't done.
For example, I don't know what's
going to happen in Georgia,
but, as we're taping this,
there are more votes to count
in Democratic areas
and that godforsaken
New York Times needle
has it tilting toward Biden.
Spent all time staring at that
thing and, every time it moved,
it was like hearing a twig snap
in a horror movie.
I feel like that needle
is a murder's ice pick
that I'm just trying
to keep away from my eye.
It's a big deal
that Trump and Biden
are even neck-and-neck
in Georgia,
and Trump knows that
because, in the final days
of the campaign,
he was whining that he even had
to campaign there at all.
-I shouldn't even be here.
They say I have Georgia made.
-Wow, what are a shock
you're underperforming there.
[ As Trump ]
I shouldn't even be
in this backwater state,
you swamp people.
When my campaign manager told me
we were going to Georgia,
I said, "Georgia?!
With those redneck yokels.
Don't those people eat rocks
and drink gasoline?"
Anyway, vote for me,
if you can figure out how
to sign your name on the ballot,
you freaks."
In fact, as we speak,
Trump's campaign is asking
for a recount in Wisconsin
and spent all night fighting
with Fox News to withdraw their
call for Biden in Arizona.
And you know Trump's
in bad shape
when he's fighting
with Fox News,
an entire network dedicated
to repeating everything he says.
That's like the Kardashians
fighting with E!
I'm told.
[ Laughter ]
So, in those states,
Trump wants to keep counting,
but, in early states
where early return had him up,
like Pennsylvania,
he's trying to stop ballots
from being counting
and suggested
he wanted the Supreme Court
to help him steal it.
-We'll going
to the U.S. Supreme Court.
We want all voting to stop.
-You can't just go
to the Supreme Court
and tell them to stop counting.
That's not a thing.
Trump talks about it like
he's just going to
walk down the street
and knock on their door.
[ As Trump ]
Hello, is Brett there?
We're drinking beers
with Tobin and Squee.
This is deeply dangerous
authoritarian behavior
and a major test
for the national media.
We have to resist this.
Trump's logic here is obvious.
It's grotesque.
He wants to keep counting
Trump votes,
but stop counting Biden votes.
If he had his way,
he'd get to personally sift
through every ballot
and cross out Biden's name.
So, as of this taping,
they're still counting ballots.
We're still awaiting results,
but, as we said,
the path for Biden looks much
better than the path for Trump,
which is why Trump and his
allies on Fox are going all out
to falsely declare victory
and discredit the results.
But, first, let's retrace
what happened last night
and how we got here.
If you were a Democrat
or a sane person
hoping for an early landslide,
as we all know,
that did not happen.
In fact, Democrats' hopes
for an obvious,
overwhelming result early in the
night were quickly dashed
in a state where Democrats'
hopes are always dashed,
the state that has toyed with
and tormented Democrats
for years,
the Loki of swing states...
The state ping-ponged
back and forth for a while,
until it eventually became clear
it would not go Biden's way.
-Welcome to the
roller coaster
that is Florida.
If you're look at Florida
right now,
it's a roller coaster.
Welcome back to the
roller coaster.
Joe Biden has pulled ahead
by 7,784 votes
in the state of Florida.
-Trump just took the lead
in Florida.
-Again, this is going to be
a roller coaster
by 28,000 votes, right?
Palm Beach turned blue.
It is red at the moment.
It the has gone back
and forth several times,
in just the last 15
or 20 minute.
Let's take a look at Florida
as we go through it.
Again, this one is
always a roller coaster.
-Stop calling it
a roller coaster.
If you're going to be
on TV for 14 hours,
learn like a second word
to describe up and down.
We know it's a roller coaster.
Every time,
we look forward to it,
then, we experience
abject terror
and we end up barfing in a trash
can and say never again.
And Florida isn't one
of those roller coasters
at a legit theme park.
It's one of the weird,
traveling carnivals
where none of the rides
have safety bars
and the petting zoo animals
are just two donkeys and a dog.
[ Gruffly ]
Don't touch the dog.
Why is it that every election
starts with Democrats
getting hopeful about Florida
and then getting burned?
It's the political equivalent
of that kid
from "The Twilight Zone."
We're begging him not
to send us to the cornfield
and then, he smiles for a second
and we breathe a sigh of relief
and then, he points to us
and sends us
to the goddamn cornfield.
And then, they are wandering
around the cornfield,
saying, "Nate Silver said
this wouldn't happen!"
And then, Nate Silver says,
"No, I said this probably
wouldn't happen."
And then we scream,
"Not now, Nate!
I'm corn!"
We were fold Biden
had a 90% chance of winning,
that the polling had been
consistent for an entire year,
that he was going to win
by like eight points.
The early returns
felt like a put-on,
like some sort
of elaborate joke.
-Election night
in America,
brought to you
by "Borat Subsequent Moviefilm."
-Damn it!
He did it again.
He's so good.
John King was Sasha Baron Cohen
the whole time, wasn't he?
I should've guessed when he said
Democrats were underperforming
in the crucial Wisconsin county
of Wawaweewa!
[ Laughter ]
Suffice it to say
election night was not fun.
After one state, I was already
deep into the whiskey
and my stomach felt
like Chernobyl.
Who could possibly enjoy this?
-This is why elections are fun.
-Oh, right, people who are
completely unaffected
by the outcome.
John King, I assure you, you
were the only one having fun.
That's like hearing
your surgeon lean over,
right before putting you under,
and saying,
"This is why
brain surgery is fun.
Oh, whoa!
I did not see that on the scan."
Another thing to remember
is that these anxiety-filled
election nights
are a completely unnecessary
product of two things --
cable TV
and the electoral college.
If we just had a national
popular vote,
like a sane country,
we wouldn't have to come up
with all this complicated math
to fend off unpopular
fascist demagogues
and we wouldn't have
to learn the names
of all 254 counties in Texas
where, somehow,
there's always more
Trump votes left to come in.
"As you can see here,
Biden doing well
in Stonefield County,
but over here
in Dinkington County,
we're expecting about 6 million
more Trump votes,
so, keep an eye on that."
And, at some point,
even the cable shows
that thrive on this contrived
drama ran out of stuff to say,
leading to moments like this --
-You see a lot of red,
but you see
a lot of blue
as well.
-Oh! Thanks, Wolf.
Are you a news analyst
or a tour guide
at the Guggenheim?
[ As Blitzer ]
There's a lot of red
and also a lot of blue
and over there
is one neon light on a wall.
So last night did not
start well for Democrats,
but we should've expected that.
We were told for weeks
that's what would happen,
that, because of mail ballots,
there would be
a red-to-blue shift,
that Republicans would look
good early and then,
Democrats would gain overnight,
and, yet,
we couldn't heed our own advice.
It's like walking into a casino
telling yourself you're going
to play one game of craps
and then, an hour later,
you're trying to sell your watch
to a parking valet
for 10 more chips.
This exact same thing
happened in 2018,
when Democrats
ultimately beat Republicans
by a record margin
and won a huge majority.
Remember how that night started?
Democrats lost races in Florida
and this is
how everyone reacted.
-When you look at what's
going on here tonight,
this is not
a blue wave.
-This is not a blue wave.
-It is not a blue wave.
-It's nothing like a blue wave
or a tidal wave.
-Right.
-It's not a blue wave.
-So we haven't seen
the blue wave.
-There is not a blue wave.
-Which, in retrospect,
was wrong.
It was a blue wave,
with Democrats winning
by a historic margin
and a national repudiation
of Trump and the GOP.
Watching all that early punditry
was like watching Jim Nantz
call the game for the Jets
after the first drive
because they kicked
a field goal.
[ As Nantz ]
Tony, I just don't see how
the Chiefs come back from this
and I'm sorry.
While I was talking,
the Chiefs have scored
21 points.
Last night, early in the night,
we all started to get
that queasy feeling that it was
2016 all over again.
I spent most of the night
clenching so hard,
I have six-pack abs now.
And, in those moments,
I will say,
I was very happy that we
weren't doing a live show.
It's like no one wants
to have a panic attack,
but, if you're going to,
you prefer to have it alone
in your apartment,
instead of on the subway,
in hush hour.
But this morning, as millions
of votes actually got counted,
it's starting to feel more
like 2018.
For one thing, Biden is on track
to win a large
popular vote victory,
which would be the seventh time
out of the last eight elections
that the Democrat
won the popular vote.
And, yet, in our ridiculous,
Rube Goldberg political system,
that's just a fun piece
of trivia,
instead of, you know,
the deciding factor.
The bottom line here is
we need to count every vote
and there are still mountains
of mail ballots to count,
which is what always happens.
As we've been saying
on this show for weeks,
this is how it's been
since the nation's founding.
You think, 250 years ago,
they stopped counting votes
at 11:59 pm on election night?
They probably didn't even
use clocks.
Ben Franklin just looked
at a candle in a jar,
guessed that it was midnight,
and then went back to sleep.
Side note -- here's my
impression of Ben Franklin
from the "John Adams"
miniseries.
[ As Franklin, posh accent ]
I concur with Mr. Adams.
[ Snoring ]
Tom Wilkinson, everybody,
one of the greats.
They did you dirty
in "Michael Clayton," T!
Also, just to be clear --
I know nothing
about colonial times.
I'm just assuming
they didn't use clocks.
Don't correct me.
This is "A Closer Look."
It's not school.
Anyway, the people claiming now
that counting votes
the morning after an election
is somehow a scandal
are just bad faith,
soulless ghouls.
They all claim to be
traditionalists
or originalists,
or whatever ridiculous euphemism
they want to use for being
anti-Democratic reactionaries.
When the Constitution
was written,
it took weeks
to count all the ballots.
That's why the electoral college
meets in December
and the inauguration
was originally in March.
Hell, it probably took weeks
just to fill out the ballot
because you had to use a quill
and inkwell.
On the other hand,
the calligraphy was beautiful.
Again, I know nothing
about colonial times,
except what I learned
from "John Adams,"
which holds up.
Highly recommend.
If you want to call yourself
a traditionalist
or an originalist,
or whatever the hell
Republicans call themselves,
then you have to own that,
but when the rubber his the road
they all abandon
their supposed originalism
and scream about how
every vote needs
to be counted instantaneously.
Trump did this for weeks,
including just this weekend.
-I think it's a terrible thing,
when people or states
are allowed to tabulate ballots
for a long period of time
after the election is over.
And I think it's terrible
when we can't know
the results of an election
the night of the election,
in a modern-day age
of computer.
-A big tell that someone is
in their 70s is
when they say something like,
"a modern-day age of computer."
You don't have to say that.
We all use computers.
They're everywhere.
They have been for decades.
That's like saying --
[ As Trump ]
We should know the outcome
on election night.
After all, it is the age
of the automobile!
What do computers have
to do anything?
They're mail-In ballots.
We're not voting online.
This is a presidential election,
not a BuzzFeed quiz.
You don't send in your ballot,
then get a letter in the mail
that says, "Congratulations,
you're a Samantha."
This argument is bewildering
in its stupidity and insanity
and we can't forgot that.
It's important to remember.
They're literally
just counting ballots.
That's it.
The ballots didn't
magically appear.
Trump has his way of making
very normal, everyday things
sound like
nefarious conspiracies,
until you take three seconds
to think about it.
You just have to take
the psychotic stuff he says
and sub in normal human details
to see how crazy they are.
Take this tweet,
which, by the way,
was censored by Twitter
because it's a deranged lie.
-He writes...
-They're not surprise ballot
dumps, Algernon.
They were always there.
They're just getting
counted now.
Trump's like a guy who loses
at poker night, whining --
[ As Trump ]
After the first hand,
I was leading, often solidly,
in many key categories.
Then, one by one, my chips
started to magically disappear
as I went all-in on a Jack high
and a surprise pair
of fives was counted.
Very strange.
Honestly, I'm at a loss
at how to explain this
any more succinctly
to these people.
I mean, what else can you say?
They're counting ballots.
That's it.
It's so straightforward.
This is like trying
to teach an infant how
to say their first word.
At some point,
all you can do is just point
and say it over and over again,
until they get it.
Banana! Banana!
Come on, man, how much easier
can I make it for you?
But Trump and Fox News have been
priming their audience
with these lies for weeks
and, now, the moment is here
and they're taking
the outrageous
and unprecedented step
of falsely declaring victory
before all the votes are counted
and insisting that any votes
that come in
for their opponent
are somehow fraudulent.
It's an authoritarian movement
intent on detonating
our democracy
and turning it
into an autocracy,
with a healthy sprinkling
of psychosis.
I mean, listen
to this explanation
from the president of the
United States last night,
as to why he falsely thinks
normal, routine ballot-counting
is somehow rigged against him.
-We were getting ready
for a big celebration.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah!
-We were winning everything
and, all of a sudden,
it was just called off.
We won states and,
all of a sudden,
I said, "What happened
to the election?
It's off."
And we all these announcers
saying, "What happened?"
And then, they said, "Oh..."
-Why does Trump
always sound like he's
describing a dream
to a therapist?
[ As Trump ]
We were getting ready,
you know,
for like a big celebration
and then, all of a sudden,
it was called off.
And I was naked in a room
full of Easter bunnies,
so I don't know.
Seriously, it's incoherent,
it's insane.
And I know we say that a lot,
but especially on this day,
of all days,
we can't lose sight of that.
This is all just bewildering
in its insanity.
Like let's go back to this.
-I said, "What happened
to the election?
It's off."
And we have all these announcers
saying, "What happened?"
And then, they said, "Oh..."
-What are you saying?
I hear individual words
that I recognize,
but the sentence structure
is gibberish.
You sound like me,
trying to give directions
in Times Square
to a French tourist.
[ French accent ]
Uh, ooh, where la boutique
de M&M's?
Uh, ooh.
Uh --
[ Speaking French ]
Septième Avenue
uh, eh uh, uh,
si tu vois
Crevette de Bubba Gump
[ Laughter ]
to eh, uh...
Gone too far.
Sure enough, Fox News picked up
on Trump's line of bull[bleep]
As soon as he ended his speech,
moments after they cut
away from Trump,
ex-Bush hack Dana Perino,
who served as press secretary
during one
of the most disastrous
and catastrophic stretches
in recent American history
before, you know,
the next Republican president,
had this to say
about Trump's speech.
-Dana, but he
was also saying,
"We don't want them
to find votes
in Pittsburgh or any other
part of Pennsylvania."
-Yeah. All of a sudden,
you're going to find
100,000 votes
that just happened to be
in some trash can behind --
I think that's what
he was talking about.
-You ghouls love your evidence-
free musings, don't you?
That doesn't belong in the news.
That belongs in a PennySaver
column called...
There's literally no proof
for what you're saying.
These people are so insane,
they think election officials
are finding ballots
the way George Costanza
found that eclair.
[ As Costanza ]
It's a good ballot, Jerry!
It was above the rim!
[ Laughter ]
Then, this morning,
Fox News went to work,
trying to sustain
the deranged conspiracy theory
that just counting votes
mean magically finding votes
because they can't
do basic math.
-This thing is
down to the wire
and it'll be Biden who has
to come back to try to grab it.
-The president
is up nearly
700,000 votes
in Pennsylvania!
You can't statistically go back
-Right.
-and tell me that that thing
is still really in play.
How are they going to go get
700,000 additional votes?
I just don't think
it's going to happen.
-One of the things that would be
a tragedy in Pennsylvania --
Philadelphia was the
birthplace of liberty
and, if a lot of these
votes, you know,
sort of suddenly
get found
and they get counted days
after the election,
it would be a real shame
if Philadelphia became
the place where
liberty also died.
-Counting votes
is not finding votes.
They're not scanning the beach
with a metal detector.
This isn't a scavenger hunt.
"Oh, look, I found a ballot,
a bird's nest, and a toy car.
Now, all we need is
an autographed headshot
of Steve Guttenberg,
and we won the election."
Again, they are
all valid ballots
that are just getting counted
the way we always count ballots,
days or weeks after an election.
This always happens.
And you, of all people,
should know that, Mike Huckabee,
since, the last time you ran
for something in 2016,
you came in ninth
in the Iowa caucuses.
You did worse than John Kasich,
who I'm pretty sure
sells reverse mortgages now;
and Carly Fiorina,
who is so unpopular,
she literally disappeared
at a campaign event.
[ Laughter ]
One of our favorites.
I hope she's okay.
It's been four years.
We probably should've checked.
[ Laughter ]
And, in case you're
confused at all
by that extremely dumb math
you just heard,
here's an actual smart person
explaining early this morning
why Pennsylvania was definitely
not in Trump's column yet.
-The big picture
in Pennsylvania,
we think there are
upward of 2 million ballots
that have not yet
been counted
and that are not
a part of this tally.
Donald Trump's lead, right now,
in what has been tabulated,
is sitting at a little bit
less than 700,000.
Again, nearly
2 million to come
and they are
disproportionately --
Pittsburgh,
Philadelphia,
Montgomery County --
Democratic areas.
-God bless Steve Kornacki.
I don't think he was off camera
once last night.
They even had a Kornacki mini
cam in the corner of the screen
when someone else was talking,
like he was a panda
at the National Zoo.
Kornacki's the new
picture-in-picture.
When you're watching Thursday
Night Football this week,
he'll be in the corner,
counting votes
in Mecklenburg County.
And, yet, Trump and Fox News
have spent months
priming their audiences
for the blatant attempt
to steal the election and call
a Biden victory fraudulent.
We knew it was going to happen
and, now, it's here.
Fox News kept putting liars
on their air,
like a supposed GOP pollster
who falsely claimed
nonexistent voter fraud
was just baked into the system
in Pennsylvania
and Fox's supposed
news anchors --
not just their opinion hosts --
actually took him seriously.
-The way I look
at Pennsylvania is,
unfortunately, I think he's got
to win by four or five
to overtake the voter fraud
that'll happen there.
It's very systematic
in Pennsylvania.
I think it's achievable
to get to four or five,
but I think that's
the kind of margin
he needs to have
in Pennsylvania to survive.
-You're not predicting that.
You're basically saying
that he will win,
but they'll steal it?
[ Laughing ] Is that
what you're predicting?
-I'm saying he better win
by 4% or 5%
to make sure he actually
gets the victory there.
I think that's the margin
he'd need
to avoid what they will
systematically do.
-It's anticipatory
to say that there's going
to be cheating,
when we haven't
seen it happen yet.
Why are you
so confident of that?
-Well, first
of [ Chuckling ] all,
Pennsylvania
has a long history of this,
especially
in the Philadelphia area.
-First of all, I didn't know
Colonel Sanders had a son.
[ Southern accent ]
We're projecting a lead
of 11 herbs and spices
for the president
on election night.
If you don't believe me,
just ask my droopy bowtie.
Second, no, there is no history
of this blatant lie
you're repeating
on national cable TV
and why are Fox's
supposed news anchors
taking this guy seriously?
Is it possible they're
not actually news anchors,
but party hacks hired
to do Trump's bidding?
Or, to put it in Trump-speak --
if you turn on on Fox News,
you have all these
professional liars...
-Saying, "What happened?"
And then, they said, "Oh..."
-In fact, the Republicans
are the ones responsible
for the delays
in ballot counting
they're now complaining about.
We could've started counting
all these early mail ballots
in states like Michigan
and Pennsylvania
before Election Day,
but Republicans refused.
-You may be thinking,
"Why are we still waiting
to hear from Michigan
and why are they still
counting our ballots?"
Well, for about 18 months,
the election clerks throughout
the state of Michigan and I
called on our
state legislature
to update our laws
to provide time
for pre-processing of ballots
that were on par
with many other states,
like our neighbors in Ohio,
who were able to count
the vast majority
of their ballots yesterday.
Now, our state legislature
chose not to make
that change to our laws.
-Yeah!
They're the ones who said no
to counting mail ballots
before Election Day
and, now, they're
the ones claiming a delay
in counting mail ballots
is somehow suspicious.
That's the con they're running.
It reminds me of that classic
Supreme Court case...
It will take time
to fully process
the results of this election,
and that's normal and routine
and that's how it should work.
Every ballot must be counted
and we can't let Trump cheat
or discredit those ballots.
Moreover,
Biden appears to have won
a sizable popular vote
victory over Trump,
who's running behind many
down-ballot Republicans.
Will the Democrats have
some soul searching to do?
Sure. But was Trump
repudiated last night?
We're still awaiting
final results,
but it's very much looking
like that's what happened.
If Trump had any
self-awareness at all,
he'd look at the state he's left
the country in and say...
-I shouldn't even be here.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.